BEGIN OUR.
HEALTH COMMITTEE HEARING
TODAY'S BURGER BEGAN AS A SUB
COMMITTEES WE DO NOT HAVE A
QUORUM.
I DO HAVE SOME ANNOUNCEMENTS OF
LIKE TO MAKE BEFORE WE START. I
WE WILL HAVE SOME TIME LIMITS I
WILL HERE'S TWO WITNESSES PER
SIDE AND WITH A TIME LIMIT OF
THREE. MINUTES EACH FOR EACH
BILL. ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WILL
BE ABLE TO STATE THEIR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION IN POSITION FOR THE
MEASURE.
WE HAVE SUBSIDY TODAY JOINING
US.
MISTER OBERNOLTE IS JOINING US
IN REPLACING.
MISTER MARK STEINORTH TODAY WHO
WAS OUT WHO OUT ILL I BELIEVE
SO.
BILL ONE BILL HAS BEEN POLL
TODAY FROM TODAY ITEM NUMBER SIX
AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY ONE. HAS BEEN
PULLED FROM TODAY'S HEARING AT
THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR. ITEM
FIVE AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY EIGHTY.
HAS ALSO BEEN PULLED FROM
TODAY'S.
HEARING I REQUEST THE AUTHOR.
THE CONTENTS WILL BE AMENDED
INTO ITEM NUMBER THREE AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN SALICIN
FONG WITH THE EXCEPTION THAT THE
DEADLINE FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH TO COLLECT DATA ON
VALLEY FEVER. WILL BE APRIL
FIFTEENTH INSTEAD APRIL FIRST.
THE FOLLOWING BILLS ARE PROPOSED
FOR CONSENT ANY COMMITTEE MEMBER
MAY REQUESTED A BILL BE REMOVED
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR. THE
BILL'S PROPOSED OUR ITEM NUMBER
TWO AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY BY MR
MAIENSCHEIN. ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
AB EIGHTEEN NINETY THREE BY MR
MAIENSCHEIN. ITEM NUMBER TWELVE
AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY TWO WOULD
AND ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN S. E.
R. SEVENTY FOUR.
WITNESSED BY A SENATOR WIENER
SO THIS POINT.
SCENE NO. AUTHORS PRESENT TO
PRESENT BILLS ARE WE WILL
ACTUALLY WOULD GO TO THE
COMMITTEE.
WILL GO WITH MR SANTIAGO IF
THAT'S OKAY.
PLEASE GO AHEAD SIR.
THANK YOU MUCH CARE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
WILL BE BRIEF IN THE INTEREST
OF THE COMMITTEE.
I AB TWENTY EIGHTY EIGHT HOW
WOULD GIVE MINERS ABILITY
REQUEST THEIR OWN RESTATEMENTS
BE ADDED TO THEIR.
TREATMENT RECORDS UNDER CURRENT
CALIFORNIA LAW MINERS. OF THE
AGE TWELVE OR OLDER CAN CONSENT
TO THEIR OWN TREATMENT WITH A
FEW EXCEPTIONS.
MINERS ALSO HAVE THE RIGHT TO
INSPECT THEIR OWN RECORDS WITH
THIS WOULD ALLOW THE DO IS FOR A
MINOR.
DID GIVE A STATEMENT TO TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY WORDS IN
LENGTH ARE ON THEIR RECORDS WHEN
THEY BELIEVE THE RECORDS
INCOMPLETE.
OR IN ACCURATE WITH ME HAVE TWO
WITNESSES.
WHO ALSO SPEAK?
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS SARA JASPER AND WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
MARRIAGE AND FAMILY THERAPISTS.
AND ASK HIM STAFF ATTORNEY I
SPEAK WITH A PROVIDERS TO WORK
WITH MINORS WHO ARE FACING
REALLY DIFFICULT ISSUES IN THEIR
LIVES.
AND IN FACT.
SOMETIMES IS MINERS HAVE TO
CONSENT FOR THEIR OWN TREATMENT.
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
SUPPORT.
THIS LEGISLATION WOULD GIVE
MINORS WHEN NECESSARY. AND
IMPORTANT OPPORTUNITIES TO GIVE
CONTEXT
TO THEIR TREATMENT RECORDS
RECORDS THAT HAVE THE. POTENTIAL
TO FOLLOW THEM AND IMPACT THE
COURSE OF THEIR LIVES.
RECENT EXAMPLES OF THIS INCLUDE
A SITUATION WHERE A SEVENTEEN
YEAR OLD WAS CONSIDERING
MILITARY SERVICE AND SHE WAS IN
THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM. SHE HAD
BEEN TO NUMEROUS HOMES
THEREFORE.
WITH NUMEROUS TREATMENT
PROVIDERS AND THERE WERE.
DISCREPANCIES AS TO VARYING IN
CONFLICTING DIAGNOSES.
IT WAS VERY IMPORTANT THAT YOU
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO GIVE
CONTEXT TO THE RECORD BEFORE IT
WENT TO THE MILITARY.
UNFORTUNATELY THE LAW DOES NOT
ALLOW THAT TO OCCUR.
ANOTHER EXAMPLE.
EIGHTEEN RECENTLY HAD CHANGED
PROVIDERS. AND SHE ASKED TO SEE
THE RECORD WHEN SHE INSPECTED
THE RECORD SHE NOTED THAT.
THE PREVIOUS THERAPIST IN
INDICATED THAT SHE HAD TAKEN A
DRUG THAT SHE HAD NEVER USED
SO AS YOU CAN IMAGINE.
INACCURACIES SUCH AS THOSE ARE
PRETTY IMPORTANT TO HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO.
EFFECTS.
AND I'M HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE.
I'M GVA AIR SIGNS THAT. CRIME
REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR LICENSED
PROFESSIONAL CLINICAL
COUNSELORS.
AND LEARN SUPPORT THE BILL WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL CLOSES
THE GAP THAT AND AN ANTENNA GAP
IN THE LAW. IN WHICH IT THAT.
SUCH AN INEQUITY OUT THERE TO
WORK VULNERABLE POPULATIONS ARE
NOT ABLE TO.
MAKE COMMENTS ON THE RECORD.
OTHER OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NO ONE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION.
SEE NO ONE BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SEEN NO ONE WE WILL OF WE DO NOT
HAVE A QUORUM MISTER SANTIAGO
YOUR BILL DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION SO ONCE WE HAVE A
QUORUM WILL BRING IT UP FOR A
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO
BOTH OF YOU MISTAKE THAT FOR.
WE DON'T THINK MISTER SOUNDS
MISTER FUNG PRESENTED TOGETHER
SO MISTER MAJOR WOULD YOU LIKE
TO GO AHEAD.
MR MAIENSCHEIN WILL BE
PRESENTING AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY
SIX.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB SEVENTEEN
SIXTY SIX WOULD REQUIRE PUBLIC
SWIMMING POOLS THAT HAVE
LIFEGUARDS SERVICE. TO PROVIDE
LIFESAVING A E. D. UNITS THAT
ARE READILY AVAILABLE TO A
RESCUER DURING POOL OPERATIONS
EIGHTY DE UNITS ARE THE BEST
AVAILABLE TECHNOLOGY TO ALLOW
BOTH CERTIFIED LIFEGUARDS. AND
LAY RESCUERS TO RESUSCITATE
VICTIMS OF DROWNING.
IT WOULD ALSO REQUIRE THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION IN
CONSULTATION WITH THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH. TO
ISSUE BEST PRACTICES GUIDELINES
RELATED TO PULL SAFETY AT KATE
THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOLS.
ADDITIONAL COSTS IMPOSED BY THIS
BILL COULD BECOME CANDY COVERED
A PUBLIC SCHOOLS FOR THEIR DOOR
DO DIRECT FEES IF A SCHOOL
WISHES TO INCLUDE A E. D.
AVAILABILITY WITHIN THEIR BEST
PRACTICES GUIDELINES.
SCHOOL MY SOLICITOR RECEIVE NON
STATE FUNDS TO ACQUIRE AND
MAINTAIN THE UNIT'S AS PER THE
EDUCATION CODE.
AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY SIX.
SUPPORTED BY THE CONFERENCE OF
CALIFORNIA BAR ASSOCIATIONS IN
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OUR
LARRY DOYLE AND KATHY RECORD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
BURRS ALERT GOMEZ A CONFERENCE
CALIFORNIA BAR ASSOCIATIONS.
THIS IS REALLY A SIMPLE BILL
EIGHT IS THE BEST WAY. OF
PREVENT HELPING TO PREVENT
PEOPLE FROM DYING FROM DROWNING.
A LIFEGUARDS CURRENTLY ARE
ALREADY REQUIRED TO USE KNOW HOW
TO USE EIGHTIES IN ORDER TO BE
CERTIFIED.
AND SO THIS BILL.
GUARANTEES THAT THEY HAVE THE
TOOLS TO DO WHAT THEY'RE BEING
PAID TO DO TO SAVE PEOPLE'S
LIVES MASTERY RIGHT VOTE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CATHY RUCKER I AM
A CERTIFIED LIFE GUARD A
CERTIFIED BY THE AMERICAN RED
CROSS ALL LIFEGUARDS.
MUST I BE CERTIFIED IN CPR AND
HOW TO USE AND EIGHTY UNITS.
.
IT A LIFEGUARDS OUT A SWIMMING
POOL IT DOES NOT HAVE A NAY DE
IN IT THE BEST THEY CAN DO IS TO
PERFORM CPR UNTIL.
AN AMBULANCE ARRIVES BECAUSE THE
AMBULANCE SHOULD HAVE ANY DO
UNIT.
BUT IF IF AN EIGHTY UNIT IS OP
AT THE SITE.
THAT.
MAKES IT EASIER FOR THE
LIFEGUARDS TO DO WHAT THEY'VE
BEEN TRAINED TO DO AND IT
INCREASES.
THE CHANCE OF SURVIVAL FOR THE
VICTIM.
THANK YOU.
IF YOU VERY MUCH.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
SO MY AND HER WITH POLITICAL
SOLUTIONS AND SO ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA TRAVEL
ASSOCIATION.
MELISSA MORE WHICH I ORDER ENTRY
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
SANTA MONICA AND SUPPORT.
MICHELLE GIVENS AT THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AS PART.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO ONE WILL BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
COMMENTS COMMITTEE MEMBERS IN.
I CAN.
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE MISTER HAD
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN PERSON
I WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND
I. AGREE AND WE WILL PUT UP FOR
VOTE WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM WE
YOU DID DOES ENJOY A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
AT THIS POINT.
MISTER SALAS AND MISTER PHONE.
TO BE PRESENTING AB SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN AND SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT.
THANK IS SHARE. MANY MEMBERS
PRESENTING BEFORE YOU ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVENTEEN A SEVEN FIRST LET
ME START OFF BY ACCEPTING THAT
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS THANK YOU
MISTER WOOD INTO YOUR STAFF. OF
FOR YOUR DILIGENT WORK ON THIS
SIMPLY BILL SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN WAS STABBED XIN ANNUAL
REPORTING DEADLINE FOR LOCAL
HEALTH OFFICERS TO REPORT CASES
VALLEY FEVERS OF CALIFORNIA FROM
A PUBLIC HEALTH. I WITH THE
AMENDMENTS WOULD IMPROVE
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN CALIFORNIA
PART OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS WILL
ESTABLISHING THE DEADLINE. FOR
THE PART IN A PUBLIC HEALTH TO
AGGREGATE OF THE DATA WILL
HEALTH OFFICERS ARE REQUIRED TO
REPORT CASES OF VALLEY FEVER TO
CDP H.. THINK OF TALKING TO
ALMOST EVERY YEAR. EVERY MEMBER
OF THE COMMITTEE ABOUT VALLEY
FEVER AND KIND OF WHAT IT'S.
WHAT IT'S MEANT NOT ONLY TO THE
VALLEY BUT JUST RESIDENTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA WE KNOW THAT FIFTY
OUT OF THE FIFTY?
I COUNTIES DO HAVE REPORTED
CASES THAT THEY REPORTED WE KNOW
THAT THE CALIFORNIA I THAT THE
CDC CENTER ESTIMATES OF A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND CASES
GO UNREPORTED EVERY YEAR. SIXTY
PERCENT OF THE PEOPLE THAT KNOW
THAT HAVE VALLEY FEVER DON'T
KNOW THAT THEY HAVE IT WE KNOW
THERE'S NO VACCINE THERE'S NO
CURE. FOR TRYING TO DO IS REALLY
TRYING TO HELP ALL OF THOSE
FAMILIES ORDER.
DEEPLY AFFECTED UP AND DOWN THE
ENTIRE STATE AND WOULD
APPRECIATE AND I VOTE.
I THINK IT'S CHAIR MEMBERS I
ALSO WHEN I THINK.
THAT SYRUP BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH THE
SALINAS ALISON MYSELF ON THIS
BILL. AND FOR ADDING THE SUPPORT
AMENDMENTS TO AT A DEADLINE FOR
THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH TO COLLECT IN AGGREGATE
REPORTED DATA VALLEY FEVER BY
APRIL FIFTEENTH NOW ABOUT FEVER
IS TRULY A PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS
ESPECIALLY IN KERN COUNTY. BUT
IS AN EPIDEMIC THAT IS QUICKLY
SPREADING THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THIS BILL IS A FUNDAMENTAL
MEASURETHEN SURE STATE AND
LOCAL HEALTH OFFICIALS ARE
COLLABORATING AND WORKING OFF
THE SAME INFORMATION.
IN SPEAKING WITH LOCAL HEALTH
OFFICIALS WE FOUND THAT THERE IS
INCONSISTENT COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN LOCAL HEALTH OFFICIALS
AND THE STATE WHENEVER PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENT MAKES CHANGES
TO HE VALLEY FEVER STATE OUR
DATA IT RECEIVES.
AS A RESULT THE STATE AND
COUNTIES ARE OFTEN AT ODDS
WITH THE NUMBER OF VALLEY FEVER
CASES REPORTED. FIGHTING AGAINST
THIS DISEASE REQUIRES OUR STATE
AND LOCAL REPRESENTATIVES
TO WORK TOGETHER TO BRING EVERY
AVAILABLE RESOURCE TO HEALTH
AUTHORITIES FIGHTING VALLEY%
FEVER. ON THE FRONT LINES EACH
AND EVERYDAY.
THIS BILL HAS BEEN A PARTNERSHIP
EFFORT WITH A LOCAL HEALTH
AUTHORITIES AND WE HOPE TO BRING
MORE ATTENTION AND RESOURCES IN
OUR EFFORTS TO BRING A TREATMENT
AND CURE FOR VALLEY FEVER
VICTIMS.
WITH US THE TESTIFIED TODAY IN
SUPPORT IS PROPERTY VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE BOARD AT VALLEY
FEVER OF AMERICA'S FOUNDATION
AND A VALUE FOR SURVIVOR.
.
SOME WOMEN FONG HAVE MY NAME IS
ROBERT PRETTY AND I'M A SIX YEAR
SURVIVOR OF THE VALLEY FEVER.
MENINGITIS WHEN THE VALLEY
FEVER.
I AM ONE OF THE.
MEMBERS OF A FAMILY THAT WAS
DEEPLY IMPACTED BY THIS DISEASE
MISTER SPOCK SOLACE THAT.
I HAVE BEEN ACTIVELY WORKING TO
INCREASE AWARENESS AND RESOURCES
FOR VALLEY FEVER SINCE I
RECOVERED MY HEALTH ENOUGH TO DO
SO.
EIGHTEEN MONTHS AGO I JOIN THE
VALLEY FEVER AMERICA'S
FOUNDATION IN JANUARY I WAS
ELECTED VICE PRESIDENT UP FOR.
VALLEY FEVER AMERICA'S
FOUNDATION IS AN ALL VOLUNTEER
FOUNDATION THAT EVOLVED FROM THE
ROTARY INTERNATIONAL VALLEY
FEWER VACCINE PROJECT.
IN THE LATE NINETIES.
FOR TWENTY YEARS WE'VE SUPPORTED
A VACCINE FOR VALLEY FEVER OVER
TIME OUR MISSION HAS EXPANDED TO
INCLUDE SEEKING A CURE THINK
COMMUNITY AWARENESS.
WE HAVE TAKEN A STRONG.
POSITION OF SUPPORT ON ALL THE
VALLEY FEVER BILLS BEAT BECAUSE
WE BELIEVE THEY OFFER SMART
MAJOR IMPROVEMENT.
AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
SPECIFICALLY IMPROVE THE FLOW OF
INFORMATION BETWEEN THE STATE
AND COUNTIES BY REQUIRING.
EXAMPLE THAT CHANGES MADE BY THE
STATE TO THE NUMBERS REPORTED BY
THE COUNTIES.
HE COMMUNICATED BACK TO THOSE
COUNTIES.
THE GREATER THE VARIANCE BETWEEN
STATE AND COUNTY NUMBERS THE
LESS WEIGHT AND ATTENTION THEY
WILL BE GIVEN WHEN THIS BODY OR
ANY ENTITY REVIEWS.
ACCURATE NUMBERS BEGIN WITH GOOD
GUIDELINES.
AND THAT IS WHAT AB SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN STRIVE TO CREATE.
AND THAT IS WHY I AM ASKING THIS
COMMITTEE FOR AN AYE VOTE ON THE
BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER OTHERS
IN SUPPORT.
ARTS HERE ON BEHALF OF THE HELP
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WHERE SAY WE DON'T
CURRENTLY HAVE A POSITION. ON
ANY THE VALLEY FEVER LEGISLATION
BEING CONSIDERED TODAY.
BUT WE'RE HAPPY TO BE WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR TO CONSIDER
MINUTES IS A BILLS BEFORE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
IS THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL.
SEEING NO ONE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS ANYONE ON THE
COMMITTEE.
MISS WALDRON THANK YOU AND THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
AND ALL THE OTHER BILLS. UNTIL
THIS YEAR I DIDN'T EVEN THOUGH
THERE WAS VALLEY FEVER IN MY
DISTRICT WHICH IS NOT IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY SO IT'S ACTUALLY
A STEEP CONCERN. SO THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING IT TO THE
FOREFRONT.
AND THANK YOU FOR OP ED IN YOUR
LOCAL PAPER.
ANYONE ELSE.
WAS ONE OF THANK YOU I THINK
WE'RE BRING THE BILL SUPPORT I
THINK YOU FOR YOUR PERSISTENCE
ON THIS ISSUE I KNOW YOU AND
WORKING ON THIS FOR AWHILE.
I DON'T THINK THE AUTHOR'S WERE
TOGETHER ON THIS AND
TOGETHER TO. CREATE A SINGLE
SINGLE UNIFIED PACKAGE ON THIS
SITE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THAT
THE BILL DOES AND JOY A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION SO ONCE WE HAVE A
QUORUM. WILL TAKE A VOTE ON
THAT.
WE'LL LET YOU GO AHEAD AND MOVE
ON TO YOUR NEXT BILL AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU THIS IS A PART OF THAT
WAS SURE THIS IS PART OF THE
VALLEY FEVER PACKAGE ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT
ADDRESSES THE LAB TESTING.
ONE OF THINGS THAT WE FOUND OUT
WHEN WE WERE. DELVING INTO ALL
OF THIS WAS
FOR SOME REASON ONE WOULD YOU
TEST POSITIVE A LAB TEST TEST
POSITIVE FOR VALLEY FEVER. WAS
ENCOUNTERED BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
WHICH IS WHY CDC SAYS OVER A
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND CASES
EVERY YEAR GO UNREPORTED.
SO WANT THINGS WE WANT TO DO IS
TO CORRECT THAT SO THAT WE CAN
GET THE RESOURCES A DEDICATED
TOWARDS VALLEY FEVER THAT WE
NEED. SO WITH THIS LEGISLATION
SAYS WANT TO TEST POSITIVE FOR
VALLEY FEVER THROUGH A LAB TEST
THEN WE'RE GONNA GO AND COUNT
THOSE NUMBERS AT THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH. WE'VE SEEN
OTHER STATES LIKE THE STATE OF
ARIZONA MOVE TO THIS MODEL IT'S
NINETY SEVEN PERCENT ACCURATE IN
THE STATE OF ARIZONA BY MOVING
TO THIS MODEL. I FOR SOME REASON
IN CALIFORNIA WE REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL.
STEPS AND I WOULD SAY BARRIERS
TO ACTUALLY COUNTING. OF VALLEY
FEVER CASES IN THIS LEGISLATION
SEEKS TO ADDRESS THAT. AND
CORRECT THAT.
.
THOSE ISSUES.
PRODUCT.
IT'S ABOUT.
LOOK QUICKLY THAT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS AT THAT
JUST BRIEFLY TO WHAT.
CINNAMON SOLACE OR SAID BYLINE
POSITIVE LAB TESTS TO CONFIRM
VALUE THE CASES AT THIS BILL
WILL REDUCE UNDER REPORTING AND
GREECE ACCURACY ENHANCE
MONITORING. AND SURVEILLANCE OF
THIS DISEASE AT THIS METHOD HAS
BEEN ADOPTED IN ARIZONA AND HAS
LED TO INCREASE IN TIMELINESS OF
CASE REPORTING TOGETHER THESE
BILLS I REPRESENT POSITIVE
SOLUTIONS THAT WILL COME FROM A
COORDINATED EFFORT AMONG FEDERAL
STATE AND LOCAL OFFICIALS. TO
LEVERAGE THE BEST IDEAS IN OUR
FIGHT AGAINST VALLEY FEVER.
AND AGAIN WITH US TESTIFIES ROB
PRETTY VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
BOARD OF THE VALUE OF AMERICAN
STUDIES.
AS I SAID MY NAME'S ROBBERY AND
I'M. FELLOW FEWER SURVIVOR AND
VICE PRESIDENT BOARD OF
DIRECTORS OF ALPHA REMARKS
FINISH WITH ACTUALLY THE ONLY
NONPROFIT. FAUCET FOCUSED
EXCLUSIVELY ON VALLEY FEVER PARA
CALIFORNIA.
AND I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT WHICH
WOULD REMOVE THE CLINICAL
CONFIRMATION REQUIREMENT.
FOR ACCOUNTABLE DIAGNOSIS OF
VALLEY FEVER
CURRENTLY THE STATE REQUIRES ALL
LABS TO REPORT POSITIVE VALLEY
FEVER TEST IT ONLY COUNTS THOSE
THAT HAVE A CLINICAL
CONFIRMATION.
REMOVING THE CLINICAL
CONFIRMATION WILL ACTUALLY
INCREASE THE ACCURACY OF THE
CASE CALVET VALLEY FEVER.
FOR CALIFORNIA IN THE COUNTY'S
MOST AFFECTED BY VALLEY FEVER
THE MOUNT OF FALL IT NECESSARY
TO CLINICALLY CONFIRM VALLEY
FEVER IS INSURMOUNTABLE.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN.
FOR ALL OF ARIZONA THERE WERE
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY THREE
THOUSAND VALLEY FEVER LABORATORY
TESTS.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN KERN
COUNTY ALONE THAT NUMBER WAS
ALMOST TWENTY THOUSAND.
IN THE COUNTY'S MOST AFFECTED BY
VALLEY FEVER THE CLINICAL
CONFIRMATION REQUIREMENT TAKES
HOURS UPON HOURS TO ACCOMPLISH.
IN THE COUNTY'S LEAST IMPACTED
BY VALLEY FEVER THE PROBLEMS
DIFFERENT.
I HAD A CONVERSATION IN JANUARY
OF THIS YEAR WITH A FRIEND OF
MINE.
ABOUT A COUNTY. THAT WAS
REPORTING ONE CASE OF VALLEY
FEVER WHERE HE PERSONALLY KNEW
AND RECALL. BEING AWARE OF HALF
A DOZEN CASES IN THAT SAME
COUNTY.
CALIFORNIA HAS REQUIRED LAST
REPORT VALLEY FEVER SINCE TWO
THOUSAND TEN AND THEY DO A GOOD
JOB OF IT.
REMOVING THE IMPEDIMENT OF
CLINICAL CONFIRMATION WILL
ACTUALLY INCREASE ACCURACY AND
ALLOW A MORE ACCURATE COUNT OF
THOSE OF US SUFFERING WITH THIS
DISEASE.
FOR THAT REASON I AM ASKING FOR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
I'D BRENNAN ROBERTS ON BEHALF OF
THE HEALTH OFFICER'S ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA AGAIN WE DON'T HAVE A
POSITION ON THE ITEM THAT WE'RE
HAPPY BE WORKING WITH THE
AUTHORS. AS THE BILL'S MOVE
FORWARD MAKING GREAT
PARTICULARLY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE.
SEEING NO ONE.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
AND SEEING NO ONE IN OPPOSITION
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
JUST.
I'D JUST LIKE TO SAY THANK YOU
AGAIN TO BOTH AUTHORS FOR
WORKING. CLOSELY CLOSELY ON THIS
AND. I WOULDN'T MATCHING
DETECTED GOOD COUNSEL I MEAN TO
GOOD DATA MEANS HOPEFULLY.
AN OUTCOME THAT WE'RE ALL
LOOKING FOR.
IN IN MONTREAL IN AND TAKING
CARE OF THESE CASES SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH A DO YOU HAVE ANY
CLOSING COMMENTS HERE THAT NOT
JUST THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I
DO APPRECIATE THAT THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AT ABOUT AND ON AS CO
AUTHORS.
THIS IS A SILENT EPIDEMIC
THAT'S ACTUALLY GOING THROUGH
CALIFORNIA WE'VE SEEN THE SPIKES
ON ONLY LAST FOR EVEN THE YEAR
PREVIOUS TO THAT SO THAT.
COUPLED WITH THE AMOUNT OF CASES
THAT WE DON'T GO UNREPORTED AND
IT COVERING OVER THREE QUARTERS
OF THE ENTIRE STATE OF THIS IS
AN ISSUE I THINK WE NEED TO. PAY
ATTENTION TO AND WE NEED HELP
ALL THOSE FAMILIES AND I
APPRECIATE. YOUR SUPPORT.
FONG.
BUT IS A THIS IS A WITNESS THAT
THESE EFFORTS GO A LONG WAY IN
HELPING A LOT OF PEOPLE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE ESPECIALLY
THOSE ENTERING KENNY SORT OF.
ARE STRICTLY AS FROM ABOUT.
STILL STILL MEANT WHEN SHRIVER
QUORUM ALRIGHT SO WHERE WILL THE
MOVE WILL BRING UP FOR A VOTE.
.
WHEN WE CAN'T GETTING SO MUCH.
MISTER GLORIA.
SO GLORIA WILL BE PRESENTING AB
TWENTY NINE NINE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN I
THANK YOU SO WHAT FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB TWENTY
NINETY NINE. A FIRST LIKE TO
START BY ACCEPTING THE SUGGESTED
COMMITTEE LIMON.
AND THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF
WORKING CLOSELY WITH MY TEAM AND
HELP CLARIFY THE INTENT OF THIS
BILL.
AS ALL OF YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA'S
THE MIDST OF ONE OF THE LARGEST
MENTAL HEALTH CRISES IN THE
UNITED STATES.
FORTUNATELY.
ACCESS TO PROPER MENTAL HEALTH
EVALUATION AND TREATMENT
CONTINUES TO BE LIMITED FOR A
WHOLE HOST OF REASONS ESPECIALLY
DUE TO LACK OF PSYCHIATRIC BEDS.
TO MAKE MATTERS WORSE UP FOR
THOSE WHO ARE ABLE TO FIND AN
AVAILABLE PSYCHIATRIC BAD SOME
INDIVIDUALS RECENTLY UNDER FIFTY
ONE FIFTY HOLDS ARE REPORTEDLY
BEING TURNED AWAY FROM
FACILITIES. IN ADVANCE IN
ABSENCE OF ORIGINAL
DOCUMENTATION DETAILING THE
FIFTY ONE FIFTY HOLE.
WE'VE HEARD OF ONE INDIVIDUAL
DRIVING IS EIGHT HOURS ONE WAY
TO IN MANY FACILITY ONLY TO BE
TURNED AWAY FOR NOT HAVING THE
ORIGINAL FIFTY ONE FIFTY
PAPERWORK.
FOR FOLKS EXPERIENCING A
PSYCHIATRIC CRISIS THAT DELAY
CAN BE THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
LIFE AND DEATH.
THE BILL THIS BILL WILL HELP
ELIMINATE ONE OF THE BARRIERS TO
PSYCHOLOGICAL PSYCHIATRIC
EVALUATION ANTI TREATMENT. I
WITH ME THIS AFTERNOON I HAVE TO
MATTER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS.
I'LL TRADE OVER HIM IF THAT'S
OKAY WITH CHAIRMAN.
MINIMUM HAVE YOU HOLD FOR ONE
SECOND WE HAVE.
THE ELUSIVE QUORUM HAS BEEN
REACHED AND SO WE WILL GO AHEAD
AND HAVE MEDI TECHNICALLY
THE ROLE.
WOULD I MARITIME.
YEAH.
THANK YOU ARE CURRY AYE WITH THE
SIMPSON ABOUT PUTTING FREEBIE TO
TO
IS TO.
WHAT TECHNICAL PART ALWAYS TAKE
IT WE'RE JUST LIKE OLD TIMES
SORRY? THAT'S OKAY LIST I.
YEAH HERE.
WHERE WELL OILED MACHINE THIS
MORNING? YES THAT EVEN THIS
MORNING.
IF AG DAY OKAY.
BONTA.
CARILLO.
BURKE.
YET AS A RIGHT ANSWER.
YOU'RE THE FIRST ONE.
FLORA.
AMONG.
MCCARTY.
THIS AREA.
RODRIGUEZ SIR.
SANTIAGO.
OBERNOLTE.
THURMOND.
WALDRON.
WE HAVE A QUORUM YOU MAY
CONTINUE MISTER MADDEN PLEASE.
THANK BIZCHAIR TWO MAD REPRESENT
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF AMERICA
BECAUSE OF PERCEIVED NOTIONS OR
THE SPONSOR OF AB TWO ZERO NINE
NINE. IS MR GLORIA OUTLINED IT
WE'VE RUN INTO THE ENFORCEMENT
SITUATION WHERE WHEN PATIENTS
COME INTO THE MERCY DEPARTMENT
AND ARE ON FIFTY ONE FIFTY HOLD.
AS WE TRANSFER THOSE PATIENTS TO
A HIGHER LEVEL OF CARE WHEN THEY
GET TO THE FACILITY IF THEY DO
NOT HAVE THE ORIGINAL PAPERWORK
FOR THE FIFTY ONE FIFTY
APPLICATION THERE TURNED AWAY.
AS MR LAUREATE OUTLINE IT
RESULTS IN DELAYS OF CARE ON
THAT OUR NSA THEY'RE GIVEN THAT
WERE IN THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
AND SHOULD BE ABLE TO USE A
COPY.
WITHOUT WE RESPECTFULLY
ABSTRACT BUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
ALEX OFTEN OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT
THINK THE AUTHOR THE SPONSOR FOR
UPDATING A MUCH NEEDED OF.
IF CURRENT LAW.
MARK WINDOWS ON BEHALF OF AS
HERE YOU CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
KURT CHILD DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
ANYONE ELSE.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
SO WE HAD NO.
.
WHICH I LIKED IT QUITE WELL MY
HANG ON A SEC HERE. HE THREW ME
MISTER OWNER OF THE BUT I THANK
YOU FOR THE MOTION. SO.
GOOD HAVE BEEN AT BRING BACK
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE MISTER RODRIGUEZ.
THANK I FIRST WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD AS A PROUD COST AMERICAN
CONTEST TO. THE REASONS WHY WE
NEED THIS BILL OBVIOUSLY WORKING
THEM WAS HISTORY FOR MANY YEARS.
AND MANY TIMES WE DON'T HAVE
THAT ORIGINAL COPY IT KIND
DELAYED.
CARE FOR THE PATIENT BECAUSE
RADICAL RETRIEVE IT. THIS IS
GOING TO MAKE IT SIMPLER AND
EASIER AND REALLY AT THE END OF
THE DAY.
GET THAT THE TREATMENT THEY
NEED SOMEONE THANKED OUT OF
BRING FORWARD AND FOR A SPORT IS
WHAT THINKING.
ANYONE ELSE.
AND MR GLORIA WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE IN A QUICK LA HAD JUST ASK
FOR NEITHER.
YOU'RE YOU'RE PRETTY FAR AHEAD
OF. SECOND SO.
I'D SPECIFIC EVER BRING THE
BILL FOR IT IS A SURPRISE IN
THIS DAY AND AGE THAT YOU WOULD
HAVE TO ACTUALLY HAVE TO HAVE AN
ORIGINAL. PIECE OF PAPER. IN THE
WORLD WE LIVE AND SO I THINK YOU
FOR BRINGING FRANK BRING THIS
FORWARD I HOPE THAT.
AS THE BILL MOVES FORWARD WILL
CONTINUE TO CONTINUE GOOD SPORT
ABOUT IT SEE FROM FROM US HERE
AS WELL SO.
THE MOTION WOULD HAVE MUCH BY
MR OBERNOLTE A SECOND BY.
MISS MISS WALDRON OTHER MOSHE'S
DO PASS AS AMENDED THEM SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. WOULD I
WOULD I MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
AYE AYE CARE CURRY AYE.
AND HERE CURRY AYE BONTA.
CARILLO.
BURKE.
BURKE AYE FLORA.
LIMON.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY.
NAZARIAN.
RODRIGUEZ. RODRIGUEZ AYE
SANTIAGO.
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE THURMAN.
WALDRON. WALDRON AYE.
THE BILL HAS EIGHT VOTES IT IS
OUT OF COMMITTEE WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR OTHER STAT ON
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TAKE THIS
CHANCE.
AND MISTER GRAY.
GRAY IS GOING TO BE PRESENTED AB
TWO TWO ZERO FOUR.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY THANK YOU ARE AB TWENTY TWO
OH FOUR ALLOWS FOR EACH MINUTE
HEALTH CLINICS TO.
OPERATE FORTY HOURS PER WEEK.
OVER THE CURRENT CAP OF THIRTY
HOURS PER WEEK AND THIS IS PART
OF AN ONGOING PACKAGE OF
LEGISLATION THAT I'VE BROUGHT
BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE OVER THE
PAST SEVERAL YEARS TO.
TRYING TO ADDRESS THE. CRISIS
OF HEALTH CARE ACCESS AND RURAL
CALIFORNIA.
MISS CHAIR KNOW YOUR DISTRICT
FOR SOMEONE MIND SUFFER XIN SOME
OF THE SAME ISSUES POSITION TO
PATIENT RATIO AND AVAILABILITY
OF HEALTH CARE ACCESS AND.
ALTHOUGH WE'VE DONE A GREAT DEAL
I IN THE PAST DECADE TO MAKE
HEALTH INSURANCE AND COVERAGE.
MORE ACCESSIBLE AND MORE WIDELY
AVAILABLE ARE PEOPLE LIVING IN
RURAL COMMUNITIES STILL. SUFFER
FROM A LACK OF ACCESS TO
HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONALS AND
CLINICS IN INFRASTRUCTURE AND
THIS BILL WOULD GIVE TEN
ADDITIONAL HOURS OF OPERATION TO
THESE INTERNET CLINICS ARE
SPREAD THROUGHOUT THE RURAL
CALIFORNIA AND. OTHER.
COMMUNITIES AND IT'S A GOOD
THING I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU
ABOUT.
AND YOU HAVE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
HAVE WITNESSES.
I GOOD AFTERNOON MONEY HIS PAUL
SOURCE AND I'M THE CEO OF
CAMERON HEALTH COMMITTEE HEALTH
CENTER SERVING.
MADERA COUNTY. HERE.
IN SUPPORT.
OF THIS BILL.
ONE I THINK I'D START BY
POINTING OUT IS REALLY AS WE
LOOK TO.
BRIDGE THE GAP BETWEEN
INTERMITTENT CLINICS IN THE
FULLY LICENSES THAT. REALLY
LOOKING TO. REDEFINE WHAT WE
CONSIDERED THE FULL TIME WHEN
LOOKING AT GREENHOUSE THAN OURS.
IF YOU LOOK AT MOST LIKELY
HEALTH MINISTER OF THE STATE
WERE OPERATING IN EXCESS OF
SEVENTY EIGHTY HOURS A WEEK.
LARGELY BECAUSE WE'RE MANY
TIMES THE ONLY RESOURCE FOR FOR
HEALTHCARE IN THESE COMMUNITIES
AND SO WERE SERVING.
MANY FOLKS WRITING TO BE OPEN
EVENINGS WEEKENDS AND AS MEDI
CAL CONTINUES TO EXPAND WHICH WE
THINK IS FANTASTIC. AND COVERAGE
EXPANDS.
THE NEED FOR SERVICES ALSO
FOLLOW SUIT AND SO.
AS WE LOOK TO BRIDGE THAT GAP
THE THIRTY HOURS WAS A GREAT.
EDITION BUT REALLY EVEN AT
FORTY HOURS WERE JUST GETTING
CLOSE TO FIFTY PERCENT OF WHAT
MANY OF OUR FACILITIES.
ARE TRULY OPERATING AT IN MANY
OF THESE RURAL COMMUNITIES IN
SMALLER COMMUNITIES.
.
THE PRIVATE PRACTICE MODEL OF A
PRIMARY CARE IS REALLY GOING
AWAY AND MANY OF THE FOLKS WHO
COME IN A STEP IN THE TAKE. THAT
PLACE OUR COMMUNITY HEALTH
CENTERS.
AND.
AS WE TAKE OVER THE FACILITIES
ONLY WORK TOWARDS A FULL TIME
LICENSE REALLY WHAT WE END UP
DOING MANY TIMES IS ACTUALLY.
CUTTING ACCESS THE COMMUNITY
WHILE WE'RE THROUGH THAT PROCESS
I RECENTLY TOOK OVER A.
MEDICAL FACILITY ARE ARE HEALTH
CENTER DID HOUSE IN A RURAL
COMMUNITY IN THE MOUNTAINS
COMMUNITY ONLY MEDICAL FACILITY
IN THE COMMUNITY SERVING OVER
TEN THOUSAND PEOPLE.
AND IT WAS OPEN SIX DAYS A WEEK.
AS SOON AS WE TOOK THAT FACILITY
OVER. UNDER AS INTERMITTENT WE
HAVE CUT BACK.
TWO DAYS A WEEK TO THE COMMUNITY
THERE AN HOUR SITTING AT THIRTY
HOURS WHERE IS PREVIOUSLY
OPERATING. AT CLOSER TO SIXTY
AND SO UNTIL WE GET TO OUR FULLY
LICENSE SO.
I'M GREAT FOR THIS BILL BECAUSE
IT WOULD REALLY HELP.
THE BRIDGE THAT GAP FOR US AS WE
WORK THROUGH THAT TRANSITION
PERIOD OF GETTING TO A.
A FULL TIME STATUS IS WHAT WE
CONSIDER YOU CAN HEALTH CENTERS
WHICH IS REALLY UPWARDS OF THAT
SEVENTY FIVE EIGHTY HOUR. PER
WEEK OPERATIONS TO SERVE THE
COMMUNITIES THAT RELY ON US FOR
THEIR HEALTHCARE.
THINK OF YOUR TIME.
GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS LESLIE MIGUEL AND I
AM THE C. E. O. FOR LIVING SEND
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORSE AND SEVEN
SITES SERVING MERCED AND
STANISLAUS COUNTY.
AND TO ADD TO WHAT MY COLLEAGUE
JUST.
LAID OUT FOR YOU AND ALSO WAS
NOTED IN THE ANALYSIS.
THE EXPANSION OF MEDICARE
COVERAGE HAS HAD A TREMENDOUS
IMPACT ON COMMUNITY HEALTH
CENTERS AND.
AND AND OFTENTIMES IT IT WE
HAVE ABOUT THE LACK OF ACCESS
BECAUSE OF THE AMOUNT OF. HAVE
INDIVIDUALS THAT WERE ADDED TO
THE PROGRAM AND SO WE ARE A
GREAT SUPPORT OF THIS
LEGISLATION AND WE AND WE.
WE ALSO ASK FOR AND AND I THAT
IS WHAT THE COMMITTEE THINK YOU.
THINK YOU VERY MUCH OF THE BILL.
MOTION AND SECOND.
OTHER OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRTH
MAY CONSUMERS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTH PLUS ADVOCATES
IN THE THIRTEEN HUNDRED
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS AND
CLINICS IN CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT.
JASON VAGUE ON BEHALF OF THE
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA PARTNERS FOR
HEALTH AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY
HEALTH NETWORK IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
RE MUCH.
SIR ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO ONE OR BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS.
I WOULD JUST I WOULD LIKE TO SAY
IT WAS GREAT THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD.
THIS THIS IS AN ISSUE FOR ME
AND MY DISTRICT AS WELL WERE
ACTUALLY RIGHT NOW IN IN A
COUPLE OF. COUPLE CLINT I LEAST
ONE CLICK A MORE OF IS IN THIS
INTERMITTENT STATUS AND IT IS. A
FRUSTRATING HOW LONG IT TAKES TO
GET FULL LICENSE STATUS AND THE
NUMBER OF HOURS IT HAD BEEN CUT
DOWN OF TO SERVICE TO PEOPLE.
WHERE THE FOR THE FACILITY
ESSENTIALLY HAS NOT CHANGED IT
IS TO WIN SAID IT'S JUST A
CHANGE AND AND AND OWNERSHIP OR
MANAGEMENT NOT MIGHT NOT OR SHIP
MANAGEMENT? AND THAT'S VERY VERY
FRUSTRATES I THINK YOU FOR YOUR
EFFORTS OF IT'S A IT'S IT'S A
STATEWIDE ISSUE.
AND.
I.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
WILL GO AHEAD AND ASK FOR A
VOTE ON ON THIS AND WHO MADE THE
MOTION PLEASE.
I YOUR CURRY MISTER YEAR CURRY
MAY THE MOTION OF MISS KOREA
MADE THE SECOND MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
IT IS THE MOST IS TO PASS
THROUGH PROPS.
WHEN I WENT AYE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN I THANK YOU ARE
CURRY AYE AYE ANGER CURRY AYE
BONTA.
CARILLO. CARILLO AYE BURKE.
BURKE AYE FLORA.
LOW MOAN.
THE MOON AYE MCCARTY.
NAZARIAN RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE
SANTIAGO.
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE. BERMAN.
WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE.
SO THAT WAS NINE ZERO.
YOUR PURE BILLS OUT A FEW TO
ACCEPTING COFFERS I WOULD LOVE
TO BE A BETWEEN ON THAT BELT.
I WOULD LOVE THAT WAS SHARON
THANK YOU ARE TO THE CHAIR THE
COMMITTEE GREAT THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK.
YES.
THE CLUB AS WELL MISTER GRAY.
WE HAVE ANOTHER COURT REQUEST
FROM MISS AGUILAR CURRY.
COULD WE BE DOWN QUICKLY ALIKE
EXCEPT THAT CO AUTHOR AND ANYONE
ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO JOIN ME.
WELL JOE I JUST YOU JUST GOT TO
MORE. SELF YOU.
AND THANK YOU FOR WE GOT THREE
MORE IT SOUNDS LIKE SO. SO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SO MISTER RODRIGUEZ YOU ARE.
YOU'RE UP SIR
.
TWO US RODRIGUEZ RECREATION
PRESENT TEAM AB TWENTY TWO
FOURTEEN.
YEAH PLEASE GO AHEAD. COULD HAVE
NEW MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
I LIKE TO START. BY ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS.
TODAY I AM PRESENTING AB TWENTY
TWO FOURTEEN WHICH ALLOWS DRUG
AND ALCOHOL RECOVERY HOMES
DEBILITY. TO APPLY FOR STATE
RECOGNIZED CERTIFICATION.
RECOVERY RESIDENTS SHOULD BE
SUPPORTIVE LIVING ENVIRONMENTS
FOR PEOPLE RECOVERING FROM
ADDICTION.
UNFORTUNATELY NUMBERS HOMES
FAILED TO PROVIDE OVERSIGHT.
THERE BEEN DOZENS OF CASES OF
OVERDOSES OR DEATH AT.
UNDERPERFORMING HOMES DUE TO
NEGLECT OR LACK OF POLICIES.
BUT THESE INCIDENTS ARE
PREVENTABLE. THIS BILL CREATES A
VOLUNTARY CERTIFICATION PROCESS
FOR HOMES THAT CHOOSE TO UPHOLD
HIGH SAFETY STANDARDS AND
PROTOCOLS.
CERTIFIED HOMES WILL BE LISTED
ONLINE AT THEIR DISCRETION FOR
THE PUBLIC TO SEE AND DETERMINE
WHICH HOME WOULD BE. MOST
SUITABLE FOR THEIR LOVE ONE.
MEMBERS RECOVERY RESIDENTS ARE
ARE NOT THE SAME ARE NOT ALL THE
SAME.
THERE ARE GOOD ACTORS ABOUT
ACTORS BUT STATE CERTIFICATION
IS ONE WAY TO FORM THE PUBLIC ON
WHAT THEY CAN EXPECT IN THE
CERTIFIED HOME.
THESE BENEFITS INCLUDE ANNUAL
INSPECTIONS A DRUG AND ALCOHOL
FREE ENVIRONMENT AND BETTER
OUTCOMES.
HERE WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY.
IS DAVID SHERIDAN WHO'S
PRESIDENT OF THE NATIONAL
ALLIANCE FOR RECOVERY RESIDENTS
AND TOM GILMORE. WAS A FATHER
HAS BEEN AFFECTED BY POORLY
OPERATIVE FACILITY. ALSO WITH US
THIS TIME. RENT FREE FROM THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION WHO CAN
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
THROUGH MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON NOW MY NAME'S TOM
GILMORE I MAY.
PRIVATE INDIVIDUAL RETIRED.
RETIRED ENGINEER.
IRISH NATIONAL UNTIL LAST
TWENTY YEARS OF VERY VERY
PROFILE US CITIZEN.
DANIEL GILMORE EARLY SUN THE
FINAL YEAR ECONOMIC STUDENT
UNIVERSITY OF OREGON PASSED AWAY
ON MARCH TWENTY FIRST TWENTY
THIRTEEN FROM AN ACCIDENTAL
OPIOID OVERDOSE.
ONE DAY AFTER HIS TWENTY THIRD
BIRTHDAY.
WHICH WOULD HAVE BEEN TODAY.
FOUR DAYS EARLIER DANIEL HAD
COMPLETED A THIRTY DAY
RESIDENTIAL DRUG REHABILITATION
PROGRAM AT THE CAMP IN SANTA
CRUZ. THAT IT ENTERED
VOLUNTARILY. MY WIFE AND I WERE
DELIGHTED TO PICK HIM UP
FOLLOWING HIS GRADUATION AND
BRING A PHYSICALLY HEALTHY YOUNG
MAN. TWO BEAUTIFUL SOBRE LIVING
HOME AND REDWOOD CITY RUN BY
GATEWAY.
TO CONTINUE HIS PATH TO
RECOVERY.
THIS SIR S. SILLY SOBRE LIVING
HARSH HAD BEEN RIGHT RECOMMENDED
BY THE REHAB FACILITY AND WE
BELIEVED IN THEIR JUDGEMENT.
DANIEL WASN'T FRAGILE RECOVERY
WE WERE WELL AWARE THAT HE'D BE
EXTREMELY VULNERABLE. TO INTENSE
CRAVINGS IN THE FIRST WEEKS OF
LEAVING THE REHAB CENTER AND
SUSCEPTIBLE TO RELAPSE.
WE SPOKE AT LENGTH TO THE
MANAGER OF THE SHOE WERE LIVING
HARSH OF THIS VULNERABILITY AND
WERE HARD TO LEARN OF THE RULES
INSIDE THE FACILITY AND OF THE
FREQUENT SEARCHES FOR DRUGS AND
RANDOM TESTING OF ALL THE
RESIDENTS.
WE SAID OUR GOODBYES AND SUNDAY
NIGHT MARCH SEVENTEENTH.
ON MONDAY WE WERE SHOCKED TO
HEAR THAT THE MANAGER HAD OKAYED
A TRIP IN A SAN FRANCISCO FOR
DANIEL AND HIS NEW FRIENDS ON
MARCH TWENTIETH.
DANIEL'S TWENTY THIRD BIRTHDAY
DON'T WORRY WE WERE TOLD WILL
WATCH VERY CAREFULLY BUT THE DID
NOT THE RULES WERE IN PLACE BUT
THE PROTOCOLS WERE NOT FOLLOWED.
THAT EVENING NO SEARCH WAS
CONDUCTED AND NO DRUG TESTING
WAS PERFORMED AFTER DANIEL IN
HIS FRIEND RETURNED. FROM THEIR
HIGH RISK VISIT TO THE CITY.
EARLY THE FOLLOWING MORNING THE
MANAGER LEFTY.
SO WERE LIVING HOME WITHOUT
CHECKING ON THE RESIDENTS.
DANIEL WAS LEADER PHONE IN THE
BATHROOM HIT PASSED AWAY EARLIER
THAT DAY. FROM ACCIDENTAL OPIOID
OVERDOSE FROM DRUGS OBTAINED
FROM ON NO ON SOURCES.
THE PATH TO RECOVERY IS A LONG
DIFFICULT ONE THAT CAN BE
LIKENED TO A CHI AND WITH MANY
LINKS EVERY LINK HAS TO BE
STRONG. AND EVERY HANDOVER
BETWEEN FACILITIES HAS TO BE
SEAMLESS.
THE CERTIFICATION OF SOBER
LIVING RESIDENTS IS BUT ONE STEP
TO STRENGTHEN THIS LINK IN THE
RECOVERY CHIANG UNLESS REQUIRE
VERIFIABLE ADHERENCE TO RULES
MOST POLICIES AND PROCEDURES.
DESIGNED TO PROTECT THE PATIENT
DURING RECOVERY.
AB TWENTY TWO FOURTEEN AS A
FIRST STEP TO MAKING THIS LINK
STRONG. I SUPPORT THE BILL.
TWENTY TWO FOURTEEN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR.
I THANK YOU MY NAME IS DAVE
SHERIDAN.
ON THE PRESIDENT OF THE
NATIONAL ALLIANCE FOR RECOVERY
RESIDENCES ARE IN OUR.
THIS A COMPLICATED ISSUES SO I
WANT TO TELL YOU A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT WHO WE ARE AND WHAT WE DO
WE JUST GOT A LOT OF PEOPLE KNOW
ABOUT US YET.
WE MAINTAIN THE MOST WIDELY
REFERENCE NATIONAL STANDARD FOR
RECOVERY HOUSING.
IT'S IN USE IN MANY STATES.
AS PART OF REGULATORY
FRAMEWORKS VERY SIMILAR TO THE
ONE YOU'RE CONSIDERING TODAY.
INCLUDING FLORIDA'S
MASSACHUSETTS OHIO PENNSYLVANIA
INDIANA IN RHODE ISLAND.
OR WORK IS BEEN REFERENCED BY
THE WHITE HOUSE OFFICE OF
NATIONAL DRUG CONTROL POLICY US
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES.
I AND ALSO IN THE SURGEON
GENERAL'S REPORT ON ADDICTION IN
AMERICA AND MOST RECENTLY. I IN
THE REPORT FROM THE PRESIDENTIAL
COMMISSION ON THE OPI CRISIS.
AUG FIRST THANK YOU FOR TAKING
OUT OF THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE ON.
A RECOVERY HOUSING IS ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT COMPONENTS OF
COMBATING SUBSTANCE ABUSE.
I MEAN ADDICTION IS A CHRONIC
DISEASE IN REMISSION REQUIRES
TIME.
IF RECOVERING INDIVIDUALS DON'T
HAVE SAFE PLACES TO LIVE TO
BEGIN THAT PROCESS.
THEIR OUTLOOK IS BLEAK AND
RELAPSE RATES ARE HIGH.
UNFORTUNATELY CALIFORNIA LAGS
MANY OTHER STATES IN ITS
RECOGNITION IN SUPPORT OF
QUALITY RECOVERY HOUSING.
AB TWENTY TWO FOURTEEN WOULD
REMEDY THAT.
ARE IN SHORT IT WOULD OFFER
PROTECTION FOR CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS FOR THE FIRST TIME FOR
THIS TYPE OF HOUSING.
IT WOULD ADDRESS LEGITIMATE
COMMUNITY CONCERNS ABOUT POORLY
MANAGED AN OVERCROWDED
PROPERTIES.
IT PROVIDES FOR AN APPROPRIATE
DEGREE OF REGULATION A NOMINAL
COSTS IN CONSISTENT WITH CIVIL
RIGHTS LAWS.
IT ALSO ADDRESSES CALIFORNIA'S
CHRONIC SHORTAGE OF WELL MANAGED
RECOVERY HOUSING.
IT'S A IT'S CONSISTENT WITH THE
MERGING BEST PRACTICE IN A
NUMBER OF OTHER STATES INCLUDING
THE ONES I JUST MENTIONED.
.
HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS OF
EXCEPTIONAL SOBER LIVING HOMES
EXISTING CALIFORNIA AND HAVE FOR
MANY DECADES.
HOWEVER A LARGE NUMBER OF SUB
STANDARD IN PREDATORY OPERATORS
ALSO EXIST IN THE PUBLIC HAS NO
MEANS FOR DETERMINING GOOD FROM
BAD.
THIS BILL WILL OFFER CONSUMERS
AND THEIR FAMILIES AND MEANS FOR
LOCATING WELL MANAGED AN ETHICAL
RECOVERY HOUSING.
IT WILL ALSO ESTABLISH AN
OVERSIGHT FRAMEWORK TO PROVIDES
LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
RESIDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES
SOME REDRESS.
IN CASE THEY HAVE COMPLAINTS OR
CONCERNS THAT SOMEBODY TO RETURN
THEIR CALL.
I JUST TO BE CLEAR THESE HOMES
ARE HOUSING AND NOT TREATMENT.
A LOT OF PEOPLE.
WHO OPPOSE THIS SORT OF
REGULATION SEEM TO CONFUSE THE
SUIT WITH THE SORT PEOPLE LIVE?
?
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA.
I BELIEVE SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL BUT THEY
ARE CORRECT THAT THESE HOMES ARE
PROTECTED UNDER CALIFORNIAN
FEDERAL CIVIL RIGHTS LAWS.
CIVIL RIGHTS PROTECTION WAS IT
WAS EXTENDED TO RECOVERING
INDIVIDUALS IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT. BECAUSE DISCRIMINATION
AGAINST THEM IS REAL.
AND PEOPLE DIE BECAUSE OF IT.
BY THE COUNTY RIVERSIDE ENACTED
IN ORDER IT'S VERY SIMILAR TO
THIS BACK IN TWENTY FIFTEEN.
AT THEIR COUNTY COUNCIL'S
RECOMMENDATION THE LAWCLARIFIES
THAT CERTIFY HOMES ARE DEEMED TO
HAVE FAIR HOUSING PROTECTION.
AND MUST BE TREATED THE SAME AS
OTHER SINGLE FAMILY HOUSEHOLDS.
THIS BILL WOULD HELP TO ADDRESS
CALIFORNIA'S SIGNIFICANT
SHORTAGE OF QUALITY AFFORDABLE
SOBER LIVING CAPACITY.
IT WILL PERMIT GOOD PROVIDERS TO
DIFFERENTIATE THEIR SERVICES.
AND GIVE THEM ASSURANCES THAT
THEIR FAIR HOUSING RIGHTS WILL
BE RESPECTED.
THAT RECOGNITION WOULD WILL
ENCOURAGE MORE GOOD HOMES TO
BECOME AVAILABLE.
ESPECIALLY ARE HARD HIT
COMMUNITIES WHERE THEY'RE MOST
NEEDED.
THIS IS CRUCIAL BECAUSE FOR MANY
PEOPLE SOBER LIVING HOMES ARE
THEIR ONLY HOPE OF STABLE
RECOVERY.
THIS BILL ALSO IMPORTED
PROVIDES A IMPORTANT
CONNECTIONS.
PROTECTIONS TO COMMUNITIES AND
CONSUMERS.
FAMILIES WILL HAVE A SOURCE OF
OF PLACES THEY CAN GO FOR EXPERT
ADVICE. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN WAS
TOMLIN FREE WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION AND I'M AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS DAVID JONES ABOUT THE
CITY NEAR ADAM STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
READ EDWARDS PRIVATE CITIZEN
LAFAYETTE CALIFORNIA STRONG
SUPPORT.
RICK WHEELER CEO OF RECOVERY NOW
MY RECOVERY RESIDENTS STRONG
SUPPORT.
GREATER DAVENPORT SENIOR IN
SUPPORT OF TWENTY HOUSE OVER
LIVING FOR GOING ON THIRTY
YEARS.
JENNIFER CARVALLO CEO OF ASH'ARI
OCCURS TREATMENT CENTER STRONG
SUPPORT.
MICHAEL PRITCHARD.
STAFF ANALYST AN SCB SERVICES
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
CRAIG QUARRY PRIVATE CITIZEN IN
RECOVERY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
PETE NELSON CEO FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM OF
ADDICTION PROGRAMS PROFESSIONALS
AND SUPPORT.
RE MUCH.
HE WANTED OPPOSITION
.
WOULD YOU STEP.
QUESTION.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS PER CHILD
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA.
WE CONTINUE TO BE OPPOSED TO
WHAT IT SEEMS TO BE A REGULAR
STREAM OF THESE EFFORTS.
TO RESTRICT RESIDENTS OF
CHOICES FOR.
PERSONS WITH THAT WITH
DISABILITIES AS YOU PROBABLY
KNOW WHAT IS CENTRAL IN A
CORNERSTONE TO OUR WORK AT
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA. IS
ENSURING THAT.
PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO LIVE AND
RECEIVE TREATMENT IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES WHETHER THAT BE
PERSONS WITH DEVELOPMENTAL OR
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITIES.
WHETHER IT'S BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DISABILITIES OR FOR EXAMPLE IN
THIS CASE.
DISABILITIES.
DUE TO ALCOHOL OR. DRUG
ADDICTION.
.
IT'S SO WHILE MANY OF THE IN
YOUR ANALYSIS I THINK DOES A
VERY GOOD JOB IN LAYING OUT.
THE NUMBER OF BILLS THAT
REPEATEDLY COME BEFORE.
THIS COMMITTEE AND OTHER
COMMITTEES IN THE LEGISLATURE.
TO TRAIN RESTRICT THOSE LIVING
ARRANGEMENTS.
RIVER LIVING RESIDENTS FOR
INDIVIDUALS IN THE COMMUNITIES
AND AND I THINK IT IS IMPORTANT
TO CONTINUE TO NOTE THAT INDEED
AND.
AS I THINK THE PROPONENTS OF
STATED THESE ARE HOME SWEET
THESE ARE RESIDENTS AS
THAT WE ARE TALKING ABOUT AND
BECAUSE THEY ARE RESIDENTS AS.
THEY ARE PROTECTED BY BOTH THE
STATE AND FEDERAL FAIR HOUSING.
LAW SO I I WANTED TO JUST MAKE
TWO POINTS REALLY.
ABOUT ITS.
FAIR HOUSING LAW AND AND HOW
THIS RENTS A STRAY I I THINK THE
EFFORT THAT THE EFFORT IN THIS
BILL IS TO PUT A LABEL ON THIS
THAT IT IS A VOLUNTARY
CERTIFICATION.
BUT WE DON'T BELIEVE THAT THIS
VOLUNTARY CERTIFICATION ESCAPES
WHAT ARE THE REQUIREMENTS OF THE
FAIR HOUSING ACT IN ENSURING
THAT THERE IS NOT DISCRIMINATION
AGAINST PERSONS. WITH
DISABILITIES AND SELECTING THE
PLACES THAT.
THEY CAN.
LIVE ESSENTIALLY IF YOU WERE TO
ADOPT SUCH A PROVISION AS THE US
YOU WOULD HAVE A STATE
SANCTIONED REGULATION. ON THE
RESIDENCES FOR THESE INDIVIDUALS
AND WHILE IT MAY BE APPROPRIATE
TO LOOK AT. THE.
THE INDIVIDUAL HOMES ONCE YOU
OPEN THE DOOR AND LOOKED TO THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE INSIDE THOSE
HOMES AND IN THIS CASE.
PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES
THAT'S WHEN YOU STEP OVER THE
LINE IS IN.
IN FAIR HOUSING SO WE WOULD.
SUMMIT THAT THIS.
DOES NOT ONLY VIOLATE THE FAIR
HOUSING ACT STATE FEDERAL FAIR
HOUSING ACT BUT ALSO THE THE
EIGHTY A.
AND I JUST WANTED ALSO MAKE NE
OTHER POINT THAT THAT THE REAL
STRUCTURE OF OF THIS BILL IS IS
REALLY REPLETE WITH THE
CERTIFICATION REQUIREMENTS. YOU
KNOW YOU GO THROUGH THIS LIST OF
OF SIXTEEN OR MORE THAT GREATLY
RESTRICTS THE ABILITY FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE SEEKING TO.
JUST RESIDE WITH THOSE THAT THEY
WANT TO RESIDE WITH OR IF YOU
HAVE SMALLER SOBER LIVING.
RESIDENTS OPERATORS WHO CAN
MEET EITHER THE.
PROVISIONS FOR THAT THE COSTS
OR THE WHOLE HOST OF
REQUIREMENTS THAT YOU'RE
OTHERWISE.
THAT THIS BILL WOULD OTHERWISE
REQUIRE TO TO MEET THAT
CERTIFICATION REQUIREMENTS SO WE
WOULD URGE.
YOUR NO VOTE ON THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
SECURE MY CAROL WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY WE ALSO ARE HERE IN
OPPOSITION TODAY.
I'D JUST WANT TO KNOWLEDGE MEAN
THE WORK AT THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AND ALL THE MEMBERS WHO ARE
LOOKING AT THIS ISSUE WE KNOW
THAT THERE HAS BEEN.
CONCERNS HAVE BEEN RAISED IN
RECENT YEARS BECAUSE. OF AN
INCREASE IN THE.
AND THEN THE AMOUNT OF DRUG
TREATMENT THAT'S BEING OFFERED
THAT'S PARTIALLY DUE TO THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT REQUIREMENTS
REQUIRED INSURERS TO HAVE TO.
PAY FOR THAT COVERAGE WHICH IN
GENERAL IS A GOOD THING.
AND I THINK THEY ARE OBVIOUSLY
THE OTHER FACTORS THAT WE HAVE
AN OPIOID CRISIS GOING ON. SO I
THINK THAT THOSE TWO ISSUES HAVE
SORT OF DRIVEN IN A PUSHED A
NUMBER OF MEMBERS TO TRY TO.
FIGURE OUT A SOLUTION TO THIS
AND UNFORTUNATELY WE DON'T THINK
THIS IS THE ONE.
WE STAND IN CONCURRENCE WITH
THE COMMENTS OF DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA I JUST WANTED
ADD A COUPLE OF OTHER.
NOTES TO MIKE THE COMMENTS FROM
MY FRIEND MISTER GILES.
FIRST OF ALL.
AS HE STATES THERE ARE ANNOYING
THE LIST OF REQUIREMENTS THAT
HAVE TO BE COMPLIED WITH IN
ORDER TO BECOME CERTIFIED.
AND WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THE
MARKETPLACE IS THAT INCREASINGLY
WELL FUNDED SOPHISTICATED
PLAYERS. ARE IN ARE OUT THERE
PROVIDING THESE KIND OF
SERVICES.
THEY HAVE SIGNIFICANT
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT THEY WON'T
HAVE PROBLEMS
ABIDING BY THE CONTENTS OF THIS
OF THIS LEGISLATION. THEY HAVE
THAT WHERE WITH ALL BECAUSE
THEIR LARGE OPERATORS AND THEY
HAVE BIG STAFFS ON.
WHO'D WOULDN'T THIS BILL WILL
HARM ARE THE TRUE SMALL
PROVIDERS THE SINGLE FAMILY
OPERATOR WHO IS REALLY PROVIDING
HOUSING TO A SELECT GROUP OF
INDIVIDUALS.
AND NOW THEY HAVE TO GO THROUGH
A CERTIFICATION PROCESS WHICH
MIGHT BE EASY FOR A BIG PLAYER
BUT NOT SO EASY FOR A SMALL
PLAYER.
IN ADDITION TO THAT THERE ARE
TO PROVISIONS IN THIS BILL WHICH
GAVE US GREAT CAUSE FOR CONCERN.
ONE IS WHAT WAS MENTIONED BY THE
A SUPPORTER OF THIS BILL
PREVIOUSLY WHICH IS THAT THERE'S
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL THAT SAYS
THAT IF YOU COMPLY WITH THE
CERTIFICATION REQUIREMENTS THANK
YOU. IF YOU COMPLY WITH THE
CERTIFICATION REQUIREMENTS YOU.
THEN ARE DEEMED TO BE IN
COMPLIANCE WITH FAIR HOUSING.
WELL WE WOULD ARE YOU FAT THEN
PUTS A TARGET ON THE PEOPLE WHO
DON'T GET CERTIFIED. AND BEGIN
IT'S POTENTIALLY BECOME A
SUBJECT OF HARASSMENT. OR COULD
OR EFFORTS BY LOCAL CITY AND
THEN LASTLY IS THE PROVISION
THAT RESTRICTS THE ABILITY TO DO
REFERRALS TO THESE COMPLEXES.
WHICH WE THINK ADDITIONALLY
WOULD HARM THOSE SMALLER GROUPS
OF THE SMALLER PROVIDERS OF
FINANCIALLY AND THAT'S NOT
REALLY WHO WERE TRYING TO TARGET
AND WHOSE CUT CREATING THE
PROBLEM. AND FOR THOSE REASONS
WE ASK FOR NOVA.
OTHERS ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
IN KNOW AND BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS COMMENTS
MISS WALDRON AND THEN MR
OVERALL.
THANK YOU I'M.
A QUESTION I GUESS MAYBE FOR THE
OPPOSITION.
WHAT ARE HOW DO YOU WHAT'S THE
DEFINITION OF THE SMALL?
SIX CLATTER WHAT IS THAT AS
OPPOSED TO THE LARGER.
YEAH THE THESE ARE SIX AND UNDER
HOMES THAT.
OUR.
AND HAVE BEEN HELD NOT SUBJECT
TO ANY LOCAL ZONING A REGULATION
REQUIREMENTS
SO THIS IS A STEP NOW INTO THOSE
SIX AND UNDER HOMES THAT HAVE
THUS FAR NOT BEEN. REGULATED.
MISTER CHAIRMAN.
MISS WALDRON SO THAT WHAT I WAS
REFERRING TO WORK THAT WE HAVE
SOME PROVIDERS WHO ARE.
OPERATING MULTIPLE FACILITIES
RIGHT THERE THERE AND
NEIGHBORHOODS YOU KNOW SO THEY
THEY HAVE A FABLE THEY HAVE A
LARGER INFRASTRUCTURE AND
CAPACITY TO MANAGE KIND OF
REGULATORY ISSUES THAT THAT'S
WHO I WAS REFERRED TO. THE SIZE
ISN'T AS MUCH CHAVEZ SIX AND
UNDER ALL THESE.
I SEE THAT THE IS WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO TO DO ARM I'M JUST ONE
OF THOSE AWAY TO COME TOGETHER
ON IT BECAUSE. AS YOU MOVE THE.
THE UP THEY SUPPORTERS WERE
SAYING.
AND I KNOW BECAUSE OF MY WORK IN
THE. WORK ON THE OPIOID CRISIS.
REALLY IF THE UPPER GAME
BECAUSE.
SO MANY PEOPLE SLIPPING THROUGH
THE CRACKS EVEN THOUGH THEY GET
SO FAR. IN THE SCOTT EVERYWHERE
THAT WE CAN HELP THEM AND MAKE
IT WORK SO. THAT'S WHY I WAS
INTERESTED IN IN THAT AND YOU
KNOW I I IS THANK YOU FOR THE
CLARIFICATION BETWEEN THE FAIR
HOUSING AND THE CERTIFICATION
YOU DON'T WANT PEOPLE TO.
YOU KNOW ASSUME THEY DON'T
COMPLY WITH FOR HOUSING JUST
BECAUSE OF THE CERTIFIED THAT I
COULD SEE THAT DOESN'T ISSUE SO.
BUT ANYWAY.
YES
THANK YOU MR AFRICAN JUST ADD.
PLEASE ONE OF THE THINGS I WANT
TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT REGARDING
THAT THE FACILITIES OF SIX AND
UNDER.
OFFICER WE ARE NO WORK IN THE
ENDLESS INDUSTRY FOR OVER THIRTY
YEARS. I CAN TELL YOU TIME AND
TIME AGAIN AND MANY OF THE CALLS
ARE WE RESPONDED A NINE ONE ONE
CALLS. THE WORKPLACE BY SMALLER
FACILITIES OF LESS THAN SIX.
BECAUSE THE WAY THEY'RE BEING
OPERATED IN AND BUT NO
REGULATION THAT NOBODY HAD ANY
POLICIES TO TAKE CARE OF THE
INDIVIDUALS AND.
OVERSEE THE ONES WITH SIX MORE
BECAUSE THEY HAVE REGULATIONS OR
BETTER SUPERVISOR NORTH THEY'RE
DOING. I CAN SPEAK FROM MANY
TIMES LIKE I SAID IS RESPONDING
TO EMERGENCY CALLS THOSE TYPES
OF FACILITIES BECAUSE WE WOULD
SHOW UP AND.
NOBODY SEEMS TO KNOW WHAT WAS
GOING ON WHO'S CARING FOR THESE
PERSONS AND AND THE TOP SERVICE
AGAIN REALLY NOT THAT'S WHETHER
CALLING US FOR JUST ONE OTHER
BRING UP FOR HIS ROTH EXPERTS
ITEM.
OBERNOLTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MISTER RODRIGUEZ I AM VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO DO WITH THIS BILL AND I WANNA
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING FORWARD.
I DO HAVE A CONCERN THOUGH AND
IT'S JUST WITH ONE LINE OF THE
BILL IT'S IN SECTION TWO.
A PARAGRAPH FIVE IT SAYS.
IF A RESIDENTS IS CERTIFIED
PURSUANT TO THISSECTION THE
ACTIVITIES AT THAT RESIDENTS
SHALL BE DEEMED A RESIDENTIAL
USE OF PROPERTY. AND USE A
PROPERTY BY A SINGLE FAMILY.
SO I UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS A
KERN REQUIREMENTS STATE LAW ON.
ALCOHOL AND DRUG.
A TREATMENT FACILITIES
BUT IT SEEMS LIKE HERE YOU'RE
SEEKING TO EXPAND THAT EXEMPTION
TO ALSO WERE LIVING FACILITIES.
AND THAT'S SOMETHING I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT AND I WANT TO
ASK YOU WHY YOU'D CHOSEN TO PUT
THAT SECTION IN THERE.
WHAT ARE SOME OFFICER DEBRA LOOK
AT WORK IN ADDRESSING AS WELL
BUT WE?
TOM COULD PROBABLY ASK YOU THAT
MORE WHAT WE COULD DO THAT AS
WELL.
I'M TOM RETREAT WITH COUNTY BE
HEALTH DIRECTORS THE ARM.
THIS EXEMPTION TO WHAT WOULD
FROM LOCAL JR ARE REGULATION
WOULD APPLY TO ANY SIX BEEN
UNDER HOME WHETHER IT'S THE
WHETHER THEY'RE DOING TREATMENT.
AND BY THE WAY SOME OF THESE
HOMES DUE TO TREATMENT OF THEY
HAVE TO BE LICENSED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES THAT DOESN'T SEEM TO BE
AN ISSUE FOR THE OPPONENTS.
BECAUSE THEY'RE SUBJECT ALL
SORTS OF OF REQUIREMENTS THERE.
BUT THEN THERE ARE OTHER SIX BED
AND UNDER THE JUST DO.
SOBER LIVING THEY DON'T DO
TREATMENT
AND THEY WOULD STILL BE EXEMPT
FROM ANY IF THERE SIX BETTER
UNDER THEY STILL FALL UNDER THE
FAIR HOUSING EIGHTY EIGHT THEY
THEY'RE NOT SUBJECT TO ANY
ADDITIONAL. ARE ANY ON LOCAL OB
REGULATION AND THAT'S THE
SITUATION NOW AND THIS BILL DOES
NOT SUBJECT THEM TO ANY
ADDITIONAL REGULATION BUT SOME
OF THESE HOMES. THEY DO GET
PUBLIC FUNDS THEY DO GET
REFERRALS AND WE THINK THEY
SHOULD BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
THANK YOU FOR THE ANSWER SO THAT
IF
STATE LAW ALREADY.
APPLIES THIS TO THE FACILITIES
THAT WERE TALKING ABOUT THAT I
JUST I STILL WARM BAFFLED AS TO
WHY WE NEED TO INCLUDED IN THE
BILL. NOW TELL YOU WHY IT'S SUCH
A CONCERN OF MINE
IS BECAUSE WE'VE HAD SOME
PROBLEMS WITH.
THESE KINDS OF FACILITIES IN MY
DISTRICT AND I WE HAVE
NEIGHBORHOODS THAT I REPRESENT
IN THE MOUNTAINS OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WHERE WE HAVE
MULTIPLE. RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT
FACILITIES ON THE SAME STREET
AND THE RESIDENCES ON THE
STREETS OF REACH THE POINT A HOW
MANY OF THESE FACILITIES CAN BE
IN ONE PLACE. IS AFFECTING OUR
PROPERTY VALUES AND YOU CAN
UNDERSTAND BOTH SIDES OF THAT
ISSUE RIGHT WAS SO
SO WE HAVE A NEED FOR THOSE
FACILITIES BUT. YOU ALSO CAN
RESPECT NOT NECESSARILY BY
HAVING RESIDENTS WANT MULTIPLE
FACILITIES ON THEIR WITH THEIR
RESIDENTIAL STREET SO THAT'S WHY
MY CONSTITUENTS ARE SO CONCERNED
ABOUT THIS AND. I AM FORCED WE
CANNOT SUPPORT THE BILL WITH
THAT PROVISION IN THERE BUT.
SHOULD YOU SEE REMOVE IT IN THE
FUTURE I LOOK FORWARD VOTING FOR
IT.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SEEN NONE WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE AUTHOR FOR CLOSING COMMENTS.
SO MEMBERS ARE. STRUCK OUT FOR
AYE VOTE THIS WEEK TO MEAN
SURELY HELP RESIDENTS ON THE
ROAD TO RECOVERY.
RESPECT GRASS RIGHT THINKING
I CAN ASSURE THINK RESTORING
SOME WOULD NOTE THAT.
OBVIOUS YOU'VE ACCEPTED OUR
AMENDMENTS AND I WOULD NOTE JUST
FOR THE FOR THE OPPOSITION HERE
THERE WAS A COMMENT.
THAT.
AND WE'VE MET RECOMMEND TO THE
AUTHOR THAT.
THAT HE CLARIFY THE BILL THAT.
THAT THIS BILL DOES NOT
PROHIBIT.
REFERRALS BY LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AND WE THAT'S
OFFERED TO CLARIFY
THAT GOING FORWARD SO OKAY.
THANK YOU SO THAT BEING THE
CASE.
DO I HEAR A MOTION.
THERE MOMENT OPTIONS MOTION.
MOTION A MISSILE YOUR COURAGE
YOUR SECOND.
SECOND BY MISTER MOM.
AND SECRETARY OF THE MOTION AT
THIS MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
AND SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL WOULD I WOULD I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE AYE CARE CURRY
AYE THANK YOUR CURRY AYE BONTA.
BONTA AYE CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE BURKE.
FLORA.
FLORA I LOW MOAN.
THE MOAN AYE MCCARTY.
NAZARIAN.
RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I. SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO
AYE OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NOT VOTING THURMOND.
WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE.
NAZARIAN AYE.
THAT HAS ELEVEN VOTES THAT THAT
IS OUT WILL LEAVE THE ROAD
LOOKING FOR OTHERS TO ADD ON
THANK YOU MISTER RODRIGUEZ.
WHEN THEY MOVE ONTO. OF MUSLIM
OWNED AB FOR SEVENTY.
THE CONSENT AGENDA.
YEAH. MOVE THE CONSENT AGENDA.
SO THE THE CONSENT AGENDA HAS
BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED THE
CONSENT AGENDA INCLUDES ITEM
NUMBER TWO AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY.
MR MAIENSCHEIN A. B. EIGHTEEN
NINETY THREE MISTER MAIENSCHEIN.
AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY TWO MISTER
WORD.
AND SCR SEVENTY FOUR MISTER
WEINER.
THEM SECRETARY BEFORE MR LOW
PRESENTS WERE GOING TO TAKE A
VOTE ON THE
AS A COUNTER.
WOULD I WOULD I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN I ACT ARE CURRY AYE
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF VOTING ON
THE BEAT.
IT'S TO.
THANK YOU ARE CURRY. AYE WITH
THE EXCEPTION OF NOT VOTING ON
AB TWENTY TWO.
SIXTY TWO.
BONTA. BONTA AYE CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE BURKE.
FLORA. FLORA AYE LIMON.
AMOUNT AYE MCCARTY.
NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ
LICENCIADO.
SANTIAGO AYE OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE AYE THURMOND.
WALDRON. WALDRON AYE.
SO THAT HAS TWELVE VOTES I WILL
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR OTHERS TO ADD
ON TO MISS THE MOMENT PLEASE
PROCEED.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS AT
THE THOMAS FIRE IGNITED ON
DECEMBER FOURTH AND BURNED ABOUT
TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY ONE THOUSAND
ACRES DESTROYING A THOUSAND AND
SIXTY THREE STRUCTURES AND
DAMAGING ANOTHER TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY BUILDINGS. IT WAS THE
LARGEST FIRE RECORDED IN
CALIFORNIA HISTORY.
AMONG THOSE STRUCTURES WERE TWO
BUILDINGS OUT BARBARA VISTA DEL
MAR AN ACUTE PSYCHIATRIC
HOSPITAL LOCATED IN VENTURA
COUNTY. THIS IS OMAR IS A
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT PROVIDER OF
INPATIENT AND OUTPATIENT MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES WITHIN THE
REGION. AB FOR SEVENTEEN IS A
VERY NARROWLY CRAFTED
LEGISLATION THAT ALLOWS THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH TO AUTHORIZE OUT PATIENT
BE HERE REAL HEALTH SERVICES FOR
A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME WHILE THE
HOSPITAL INPATIENT SERVICES. ARE
SUSPENDED BECAUSE OF FIRE DAMAGE
WE HAVE WORKED WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
AGENCY CDP H. AND STAKEHOLDERS
TO CRAFT THIS NARROW SOLUTION
WITH ME TO TO ADD HERE TODAY TO
TESTIFY IS JENNIFER I NEED HOUSE
SEE OVER A VISTA DEL MAR ACUTE
PSYCHIATRIC HOSPITAL AND
CATHERINE START PRINCIPLE A
CAPITAL PARTNERS TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
MOVE THE BILL.
THE MOTION SEC
PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JENNIFER AND
I HIGHS CEO OF THE SADDAM OUR
HOSPITAL AND. AS.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN WHO MOANED
STATED OUR HOSPITALS CRITICAL TO
THE COMMUNITY THAT WE SERVE BOTH
FOR INPATIENT OUTPATIENT
SERVICES. WHO ARE WORKING TO
BRING BACK OUR FIFTY FIVE OR
EIGHTY SEVEN UP PREVIOUS BAD
ONLINE IN THE MEANTIME WE ARE
FULLY PREPARED TO BEGIN OUT OUT
PATIENT SERVICES? OPERATION
SERVICES PROVIDE.
.
THERAPY GROUPS SUPPORT GROUPS
FAMILY SUPPORT AS WELL FOR
ADOLESCENTS AND ADULTS AND THIS
IS USING EVIDENCE BASED
CURRICULUM. WITH.
FOCUSING A CHECK IDENTIFICATION
SUPPORT SYSTEM IDENTIFICATION.
FOR.
ADOLESCENTS AND ADULTS IN THEIR
FAMILIES ON THIS THAT THESE
SERVICES ARE SEVERELY LACKING IN
OUR COMMUNITIES SO I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
CAVANAUGH SAYS GARBED IN A
FACILITY I'M HERE FREE TECHNICAL
SUPPORT BUT I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK
THE COMMITTEE AND STAFF WHO ONLY
BROUGHT THIS TO THEM. VERY
QUICKLY RESPONDED AND CRY ALOUD
FOR A GREAT DEAL SUPPORT AS WITH
THIS PROCESS SO I'M IT'S A QUICK
PROCESS AND I WOULD BE REMISS IF
I DIDN'T THINK THE COMMITTEE AND
STAFF.
BUT ON BOTH SIDES FOR THEIR
HELP SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
BURST ELIZABETH ESPINOSA ON
BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN THE COUNTY OF
VENTURA ALSO IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION.
SEE NO ONE TO BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
MISBEHAVIOR HURRY HOME THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS AFFORD AND I
JUST HAVE TO SAY IS THAT WE'VE
ALL BEEN IN THE SITUATION. AND
WE NEED TO HELP THOSE THAT ARE
IN NEED RIGHT NOW AND I'M
SHOCKED IS ONLY HER NEED DAYS
THAT YOU'RE PUTTING ON THIS
BECAUSE WORTH KIND ALL GOING TO
PTSD AFTER A TERRIBLE EVENT
CATASTROPHIC EVENTS SO. THEY FOR
BEING THIS FOURTEEN HOPING WE
CAN HELP YOU ARE RESIDENTS
SOONER THAN LATER.
ANYONE ELSE.
I WOULD DIE TO LIKE THINK YOU'RE
BRING THIS FORWARD AND IT'S.
WE'RE GOING TO DO THIS IN WHAT
WE CALL THE CALL A GALACTIC
LIGHTS LEGISLATIVE LIGHT SPEED
TO GET THIS THROUGH HOPEFULLY.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION.
BY MISTAKE YOUR CAREER BELIEVE.
AND THE SECOND BY MISTER
OBERNOLTE OF THE THE MOTION IS
ON THE RECOMMENDATION TO KIRK
TINKER IN SENATE AMENDMENTS.
MOVE DIFFERENT THAN TEN ARE
NORMAL VOTE SO.
SO AT THIS POINT WOULD HAVE
MEANT TO PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE.
WOULD I WOULD I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN I AM HERE CURRY I'M
TAG HERE CURRY AYE BONTA. AYE
BONTA AYE CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE BURKE.
FLORA. FLORA AYE LOW MOAN AYE
THE MULTI MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I IN THIS AREA.
NAZARIAN AYE RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE AYE THURMOND.
WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE.
THIS THIRTEEN ZERO YOUR BILL
LET'S OUT I SUSPECT WE'LL SEE IT
ON THURSDAY.
OKAY WARY GET.
OKAY AWESOME THAT'S GREAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AT THIS POINT
WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE TOP OF THE
AGENDA WE HAVE GONE THROUGH ALL
OF THE BILLS AT THIS POINT.
PLEASE DON'T.
RIGHT SO ITEM NUMBER ONE AB
SEVENTEEN SIXTY SIX MISTER
MAIENSCHEIN WOULD BE HAPPY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
THE MOTION BY MISS WALDRON A
SECOND BY MISTER RODRIGUEZ.
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WOULD I WOULD I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE AYE CARE CURRY
AYE AYE CARE CURRY AYE BONTA.
BONTA AYE CARILLO. CARILLO AYE
BURKE.
FLORA AYE FLORA AYE LIMON. BLOWN
AYE MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE
NAZARIAN. NAZARIAN AYE
RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
AYE. OBERNOLTE. OBERNOLTE AYE
THURMOND.
WALDRON. WALDRON AYE.
THAT IS THIRTEEN ZERO UMMC MOVE
ON TO.
WELL GO BACK TO THE CONSECUTIVE
SINCE THAT'S.
THE NEXT PART OF NEXT ITEM SO
THE CONSENT CALENDAR INCLUDES.
ITEM NUMBER TWO AB SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY. ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB
EIGHTEEN NINETY THREE ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE AB TWENTY TWO
SIXTY TWO AND ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN SCR SEVENTY FOUR SO.
HEAVY OPEN THE ROLAND CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
BURKE.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I.
THURMOND.
THURMOND I.
IT'S BURKE ON THE CONCERT
COUNTER. BURKE ARE A.
TEENS ZERO ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AND FOURTEEN ZERO
TWENTY TWO.
SO THAT'S FIFTEEN ZERO ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AND.
FOURTEEN ZERO ON TWENTY TWO
SIXTY TWO.
SO.
ITEM NUMBER THREE AB SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN..
THANK YOU.
MOTION BY MISTER OBERNOLTE
SECOND I MISSED LA MONDE.
CORRECT I GOT THAT RIGHT OR MISS
BURKE OKAY I'M SORRY.
I'VE BEEN WRONG A LOT TODAY SO
WAS AT THE DOUBLE ASK THIS ONE
SO THANK YOU MISS BURKE SO.
MOTION IS TO PASS. AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS BEEN A SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE UP TO MEMBERS.
OF THE ROLE OPEN THE ROACHES
MAKE THEIR MIND. BROUGHT WE'RE
ALL ABSENT HERE WE'RE ALL HERE.
WHAT I WOULD AYE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE I GET ARE CURRY
AGAR CURRY AYE BONTA MONTHS I
CARILLO?
CARILLO AYE BURKE BURKE AYE
FLORA FLORA AYE LIMON.
THE MOAN AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
NAZARIAN.
IS THERE AN AYE RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ LIE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
IBOOK OBERNOLTE. OBERNOLTE AYE
THURMAN. THEREIN AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE FIFTEEN SIR.
AS A FIFTEEN YEAR ON IT JUST
FOR.
JUST FOR CONTINUITY WERE ALMOND
JUMP UP TO NUMBER ONE AGAIN
THERE A COUPLE MEMBERS WHO JUST
POPPED IN.
AT THE OPEN AS ROLAND THAT THEY
WILL GO BACK TO NUMBER FOUR.
BURKE.
BURKE I.
THURMOND. THURMAN I FIFTEEN ZERO
GREAT THANK YOU SO NOW WE ARE AT
ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT.
THINGS LIKE.
MOTION THAT MISTER OBERNOLTE
SECOND BY MISTAKE YOUR CURRY.
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS ABOUT SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WOOD I WOULD I MAIENSCHEIN.
IT'S KIND I AGAR CURRY AYE AGAR
CURRY AYE BONTA. BONSAI CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE BURKE.
BURKE AYE FLORA. FLORA I LOVE
MONIQUE LIMON I'VE MCCARTY
MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ
AYE SANTIAGO ON SANTIAGO AYE OF
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE
THURMOND.
THURMOND AYE WALDRON. WALDRON
AYE.
FIFTEEN ZERO MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT.
AB TWENTY EIGHTY EIGHT MISTER
SANTIAGO.
ENTERTAIN A MOTION MOVE.
BUT THE BILL IS NOT A YEAR
CURRY.
SECOND MISSED AMOUNT. OF
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WOULD I WOULD I DON'T.
THOSE ARE TO PASS AS A PROPOSED
TO PASS TO PREPARATIONS EXCUSE
ME.
WOULD I WOULD I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE AYE CARE CURRY.
AYE CAREFREE AYE BONTA BONTA AYE
CARILLO. CAREER.
CORREO I.
BURKE.
BURKE I FLORA FLORA AYE LIMON.
LOW MOAN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ LICENSE IAGO SANTIAGO
AYE OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE
THURMAN. THURMOND AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE.
THAT'S FIFTEEN ZERO MOVING ON TO
ITEM NUMBER NINE.
AB TWENTY NINETY NINE MISTER
GLORIA.
PLEASE.
OVER THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
BONTA.
BONTA AYE CARILLO.
CORREO AYE FLORA.
FLORA I. MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE
NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN ICELAND THIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE THURMOND.
BERMAN I.
THAT'S ALSO FIFTEEN ZERO ITEM
NUMBER TEN AB TWENTY TWO OH FOR
MISTER GRAY. PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
BONTA.
BONTA AYE FLORA. FLORA I.
MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE THURMOND.
THURMOND I.
IT'S ALSO FIFTEEN ZERO ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN AB TWENTY TWO
FOURTEEN MISTER RODRIGUEZ PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS BURKE.
BURKE I AM MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I.
OBERNOLTE.
OKAY GOING BACK.
NOT VOTING I'M SIR.
TWENTY TWO FOURTEEN THIS BURKE
BURKE NOT VOTING.
MCCARTY I.
OBERNOLTE.
HE WAS NOT
ABOUT NOT VOTING. THURMAN.
THURMOND I.
THIRTEENTH. AND THEN FINALLY AB
FOR SEVENTEEN I MISSED LOW MOAN.
BURKE.
BURKE AYE THURMOND.
PERRANCE I FIFTEEN ZERO FIFTEEN
ZERO. THAT CONCLUDES OUR
COMMITTEE MEETING THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND HAVE A GREAT AFTERNOON